LOT OF SPECULATION ABOUT WHAT
THE NEW ENGLAND PATRIOTS ARE
GOING TO DO. COULD THEY TRADE
UP? IF ONE OF THESE GUYS LIKE
TRAIL ANTS SLIPS PAST THE TOP
TEN BILL BELICHICK DROPPING
SOME BREADCRUMBS LAST WEEK TO
SUGGEST. MAYBE THEY WOULD WE
CAN'T OVERLOOK THE FACT A
SIMS AND I DISCUSSED TODAY
THAT BELLA CHECKED.
LOVE'S CAM NEWTON AND ONE OF
THE REASONS HE LOVES CAM
NEWTON AT A TIME WHEN TOPIC A
THROUGHOUT THE NFL GUYS
CHOOSING TO STAY AWAY FROM
VOLUNTARY OFFSEASON WORKOUTS
WHO'S THERE WITH BELLS ON DAY
ONE CAM NEWTON READY TO DO
WHAT HE DIDN'T HAVE THE
CHANCE TO DO LAST YEAR DIDN'T
JOIN THE PATRONS UNTIL LATE.
JUNE WASN'T AVAILABLE TO DO
JOIN THE PATRONS UNTIL LATE
ANYTHING UNTIL TRAINING CAMP
JUNE WASN'T AVAILABLE TO DO
WAS LEARNING ON THE FLY. NOW.
ANYTHING UNTIL TRAINING CAMP
HE KNOWS THE OFFENSE. HE'S
WAS LEARNING ON THE FLY. NOW.
LEARNING IT BETTER. HE'S IN
HE KNOWS THE OFFENSE. HE'S
THE BUILDING. HE'S AROUND
LEARNING IT BETTER. HE'S IN
HE'S SOAKING IT IN.
THE BUILDING. HE'S AROUND
THAT'S ALL THE PATRIOTS CAN
HE'S SOAKING IT IN.
REALLY ASK FOR AND I THINK
THAT'S ALL THE PATRIOTS CAN
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
REALLY ASK FOR AND I THINK
THEY MAYBE SHOULDN'T BE
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
DESPERATE TO FIND A
THEY MAYBE SHOULDN'T BE
QUARTERBACK. THEY CAN DEVELOP
DESPERATE TO FIND A
BECAUSE THESE GUYS ONLY
QUARTERBACK. THEY CAN DEVELOP
A DECADE INTO HIS CAREER.
BECAUSE THESE GUYS ONLY
HE'S GOT YEARS LEFT. YOU
A DECADE INTO HIS CAREER.
DON'T HAVE TO GO DRAFT THE
HE'S GOT YEARS LEFT. YOU
GUY THAT'S GOING TO SIT
DON'T HAVE TO GO DRAFT THE
BEHIND CAM NEWTON MAYBE FOR
GUY THAT'S GOING TO SIT
TWO THREE FOUR YEARS LIKE A
BEHIND CAM NEWTON MAYBE FOR
JORDAN LOVING GREEN BAY. SO I
TWO THREE FOUR YEARS LIKE A
THINK THIS CAM NEWTON FACTOR
JORDAN LOVING GREEN BAY. SO I
HE'S THERE. HE'S GETTING
THINK THIS CAM NEWTON FACTOR
READY AND I THINK HE'S GONNA
HE'S THERE. HE'S GETTING
BE PRETTY GOOD THIS YEAR. I
READY AND I THINK HE'S GONNA
THINK THAT MAKES IT
BE PRETTY GOOD THIS YEAR. I
IT LESS LIKELY THE PATRIOTS
THINK THAT MAKES IT
GO ALL IN ON A QUARTERBACK IN
IT LESS LIKELY THE PATRIOTS
ROUND ONE AND TRY TO MAYBE
GO ALL IN ON A QUARTERBACK IN
MOVE UP TO GET ONE OF THE TOP
ROUND ONE AND TRY TO MAYBE
FIVE FIVE GUYS MILES. OKAY,
MOVE UP TO GET ONE OF THE TOP
TWO THINGS. I MEAN, HEY, I
FIVE FIVE GUYS MILES. OKAY,
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW THAT I
TWO THINGS. I MEAN, HEY, I
SEE THE FEATURE IS MOVING ALL
DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW THAT I
THE WAY UP, YOU KNOW, JUST
SEE THE FEATURE IS MOVING ALL
THAT DOESN'T MEAN I'M GONNA
THE WAY UP, YOU KNOW, JUST
BE IN THEIR AMMO BUT NEITHER
THAT DOESN'T MEAN I'M GONNA
DID, YOU KNOW SIGNING ALL
BE IN THEIR AMMO BUT NEITHER
THOSE FREE AGENTS, BUT ALSO I
DID, YOU KNOW SIGNING ALL
JUST I DON'T KNOW ABOUT CAM
THOSE FREE AGENTS, BUT ALSO I
NEWTON AND I JUST I THINK
JUST I DON'T KNOW ABOUT CAM
THAT HE WAS AN EFFECTIVE
NEWTON AND I JUST I THINK
QUARTERBACK AT SOME POINTS IN
THAT HE WAS AN EFFECTIVE
SEASON LAST YEAR AND I THINK
QUARTERBACK AT SOME POINTS IN
COVID SEEM TO AFFECT HIM AND
SEASON LAST YEAR AND I THINK
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT THE
COVID SEEM TO AFFECT HIM AND
NUMBERS PRE AND POST COVID
YOU KNOW, YOU LOOK AT THE
THERE WERE SOME THINGS THERE
NUMBERS PRE AND POST COVID
THAT ARE KIND OF EYE-OPENING,
THERE WERE SOME THINGS THERE
I ALSO JUST I DON'T KNOW YOU
THAT ARE KIND OF EYE-OPENING,
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE GAMES
I ALSO JUST I DON'T KNOW YOU
THAT HE HAD AND I DIDN'T
LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE GAMES
WATCH EVERY SINGLE PATRIOTS
THAT HE HAD AND I DIDN'T
GAME LAST YEAR, BUT I AM AN
WATCH EVERY SINGLE PATRIOTS
EYE ON THAT GAME THAT HE
GAME LAST YEAR, BUT I AM AN
PLAYED AGAINST LOS ANGELES
EYE ON THAT GAME THAT HE
RAMS ON THURSDAY NIGHT
PLAYED AGAINST LOS ANGELES
FOOTBALL MAN MY GOODNESS. I
RAMS ON THURSDAY NIGHT
KNOW THAT THE RAMS DEFENSE
FOOTBALL MAN MY GOODNESS. I
WAS THE BEST IN THE LEAGUE
KNOW THAT THE RAMS DEFENSE
LAST YEAR, BUT BOY, HE JUST
WAS THE BEST IN THE LEAGUE
GAVE NEWTON DID NOT LOOK LIKE
LAST YEAR, BUT BOY, HE JUST
YOU COULD BE AN EFFECTIVE
GAVE NEWTON DID NOT LOOK LIKE
QUARTERBACK FOR A 17 GAMES.
YOU COULD BE AN EFFECTIVE
SEASON AND BY THAT, I MEAN
QUARTERBACK FOR A 17 GAMES.
SOMEBODY THAT YOU CAN RELY ON
SEASON AND BY THAT, I MEAN
TO ALSO MAKE THE THROWS AS
SOMEBODY THAT YOU CAN RELY ON
WELL AS THE RUNS THAT HE CAN
TO ALSO MAKE THE THROWS AS
OBVIOUSLY MAKE AND SO I DON'T
WELL AS THE RUNS THAT HE CAN
DESPERATE TO FIND A
OBVIOUSLY MAKE AND SO I DON'T
QUARTERBACK. BUT AT THE SAME
DESPERATE TO FIND A
TIME, I'M JUST NOT SURE IF
QUARTERBACK. BUT AT THE SAME
CAM NEWTON IS GOING TO BE THE
TIME, I'M JUST NOT SURE IF
GUY WHO'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CAM NEWTON IS GOING TO BE THE
LEAD YOU TO THE PROMISED LAND
GUY WHO'S GOING TO BE ABLE TO
FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT YOUR
LEAD YOU TO THE PROMISED LAND
QUARTERBACK KIND OF HAS TO
FROM THE STANDPOINT THAT YOUR
RIGHT? AND I MEAN, THIS IS
QUARTERBACK KIND OF HAS TO
ALMOST THE SAME THING. WE
RIGHT? AND I MEAN, THIS IS
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT WITH
ALMOST THE SAME THING. WE
CONVINCED THE CAM NEWTON CAN
WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT WITH
DO THAT BUT I THINK WHEN
CONVINCED THE CAM NEWTON CAN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GUYS
DO THAT BUT I THINK WHEN
COMING IN AND MAKING SURE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GUYS
COACHES TO WIN A ROSTER SPOT.
COMING IN AND MAKING SURE
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE MEAN.
COACHES TO WIN A ROSTER SPOT.
THIS IS WHY ALL THIS NFLPA
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE MEAN.
STUFF AND ALL THESE
THIS IS WHY ALL THIS NFLPA
WHATEVER. THEY'RE GONNA SAY
STUFF AND ALL THESE
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO SAY,
WHATEVER. THEY'RE GONNA SAY
BUT GUYS ARE STILL GOING TO
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO SAY,
SHOW UP BECAUSE GUYS WANT A
BUT GUYS ARE STILL GOING TO
JOB AND WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
SHOW UP BECAUSE GUYS WANT A
IT, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
JOB AND WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
SELFISH IN THAT REGARD. IF
IT, THEY'RE GOING TO BE
YOU CAN EVEN CALL IT THAT AND
SELFISH IN THAT REGARD. IF
SHOW UP TO THESE VOLUNTARY
YOU CAN EVEN CALL IT THAT AND
WORK OUT SO THEY GET A LEG UP.
SHOW UP TO THESE VOLUNTARY
CAM NEWTON DID MEDIA DOESN'T
WORK OUT SO THEY GET A LEG UP.
NEED ME TO TAKE UP HIS CAUSE
CAM NEWTON DID MEDIA DOESN'T
HE'S A FORMER NFL MVP THERE
NEED ME TO TAKE UP HIS CAUSE
WERE PROBLEMS LAST YEAR AND I
HE'S A FORMER NFL MVP THERE
REALLY DO THINK IT WAS A
WERE PROBLEMS LAST YEAR AND I
COVID-19 SITUATION AND THINK
REALLY DO THINK IT WAS A
ABOUT THIS THEY WENT TO LA
COVID-19 SITUATION AND THINK
FOR TWO GAMES WITH ONLY THREE
ABOUT THIS THEY WENT TO LA
DAYS BETWEEN THEM. THEY
FOR TWO GAMES WITH ONLY THREE
PLAYED ON A SUNDAY. THEY
DAYS BETWEEN THEM. THEY
PLAYED ON A THURSDAY ON
PLAYED ON A SUNDAY. THEY
SUNDAY. THEY LOOK GREAT
PLAYED ON A THURSDAY ON
AGAINST THE CHARGERS. IT WAS
SUNDAY. THEY LOOK GREAT
AGAINST THE RAMS AND IT WENT
AGAINST THE CHARGERS. IT WAS
AND NEWTON HE DENIED HAVING
AGAINST THE RAMS AND IT WENT
BRAIN FOG IN THE AFTERMATH OF
AND NEWTON HE DENIED HAVING
HAVING COVID. SOMETHING
BRAIN FOG IN THE AFTERMATH OF
WASN'T RIGHT BECAUSE PRE
HAVING COVID. SOMETHING
SAMPLE SIZE. UGE
WASN'T RIGHT BECAUSE PRE
THEY BEAT THE CRAP OUT OF THE
SAMPLE SIZE. UGE
RAIDERS AND I THINK THEY
THEY BEAT THE CRAP OUT OF THE
COULD HAVE GIVEN THE CHIEFS
RAIDERS AND I THINK THEY
EVERYTHING. THEY COULD HANDLE
COULD HAVE GIVEN THE CHIEFS
THEY DID THEY DID GIVE THE
EVERYTHING. THEY COULD HANDLE
CHIEFS EVERYTHING. THEY CAN
THEY DID THEY DID GIVE THE
HANDLE WITHOUT CAM NEWTON. SO
CHIEFS EVERYTHING. THEY CAN
YOU'RE AT A TIME WHEN WE'VE
HANDLE WITHOUT CAM NEWTON. SO
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT GUYS WHO
YOU'RE AT A TIME WHEN WE'VE
AREN'T GOING TO BE THERE OR
HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT GUYS WHO
WHO SAY THEY AREN'T GOING TO
AREN'T GOING TO BE THERE OR
BE THERE. THERE'S BEEN A LOT
WHO SAY THEY AREN'T GOING TO
OF HUFF AND PUFF OVER THE
BE THERE. THERE'S BEEN A LOT
COURSE OF THE LAST WEEK.
OF HUFF AND PUFF OVER THE
WE'LL SEE HOW MANY HOUSES GET
COURSE OF THE LAST WEEK.
NEWTON IS THERE DAY ONE AND
WE'LL SEE HOW MANY HOUSES GET
WHEN YOU CONSIDER ALL THE
NEWTON IS THERE DAY ONE AND
GUYS THEY'VE ADDED AT THE
WHEN YOU CONSIDER ALL THE
SKILL POSITION SPECIFICALLY
GUYS THEY'VE ADDED AT THE
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
SKILL POSITION SPECIFICALLY
DIFFERENT CAM NEWTON THIS
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE A
YEAR AND I THINK OF BILL
DIFFERENT CAM NEWTON THIS
BELICHICK BELIEVES THAT THAT
YEAR AND I THINK OF BILL
MAKES HIM MORE LIKELY TO SAY
BELICHICK BELIEVES THAT THAT
THANK YOU THAT THERE'S GOING
MAKES HIM MORE LIKELY TO SAY
TO BE FIVE QUARTERBACKS TAKEN
THANK YOU THAT THERE'S GOING
BEFORE I PICK AT NUMBER 15
TO BE FIVE QUARTERBACKS TAKEN
INSTEAD OF I HAVE TO GO GET
BEFORE I PICK AT NUMBER 15
ONE OF THEM THE SECOND TIME
INSTEAD OF I HAVE TO GO GET
YOU'VE REFERENCED THE THREE
ONE OF THEM THE SECOND TIME
LITTLE PIGS. I FEEL LIKE IN
YOU'VE REFERENCED THE THREE
THE LAST TWO OR THREE WEEKS
LITTLE PIGS. I FEEL LIKE IN
MIKE, YOU'RE JUST READING
THE LAST TWO OR THREE WEEKS
NURSERY RHYMES. IT'S GOING ON
MIKE, YOU'RE JUST READING
WITH YOU MAN. I I LIKE SAYING
NURSERY RHYMES. IT'S GOING ON
HUFF AND PUFF IN THAT CONTEXT
WITH YOU MAN. I I LIKE SAYING
AND ONLY THAT CONTEXT.
HUFF AND PUFF IN THAT CONTEXT
HAT'S
AND ONLY THAT CONTEXT.
NO, BUT I MEAN I AGREE WITH
HAT'S
YOU AT THE CERTAIN POINT
NO, BUT I MEAN I AGREE WITH
RIGHT LIKE IT JUST IT FEELS
YOU AT THE CERTAIN POINT
LIKE THE PATRIOTS COULD
RIGHT LIKE IT JUST IT FEELS
CERTAINLY WAIT UNTIL THEIR
LIKE THE PATRIOTS COULD
GET ON THE CLOCK AT 15. SEE
CERTAINLY WAIT UNTIL THEIR
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM.
GET ON THE CLOCK AT 15. SEE
MAYBE IF A QUARTERBACK DOES
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM.
SLIP IF IT'S A GUY THAT THEY
MAYBE IF A QUARTERBACK DOES
REALLY FEEL LIKE THEY BELIEVE
SLIP IF IT'S A GUY THAT THEY
IN. YEAH, YOU PICK HIM THERE
REALLY FEEL LIKE THEY BELIEVE
OR YOU KNOW, MAYBE YOU JUST
IN. YEAH, YOU PICK HIM THERE
TRADE BACK AND YOU DO THE
OR YOU KNOW, MAYBE YOU JUST
THING THAT I FEEL LIKE YOU
TRADE BACK AND YOU DO THE
WOULD THINK THE PATRIOTS
THING THAT I FEEL LIKE YOU
WOULD DO WHICH IS GAIN A
WOULD THINK THE PATRIOTS
LITTLE BIT MORE PICS GAIN
WOULD DO WHICH IS GAIN A
SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY THERE
LITTLE BIT MORE PICS GAIN
YOU WANT TO DO AND CONTINUE
SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY THERE
TO TRY TO BUILD THIS OFFENSE
YOU WANT TO DO AND CONTINUE
AROUND CAM NEWTON? I
TO TRY TO BUILD THIS OFFENSE
WHY SOMEONE WOULD WANT TO
AROUND CAM NEWTON? I
SOMEONE WOULD WANT TO BUILD
WHY SOMEONE WOULD WANT TO
THEIR OFFENSE AROUND SOMEBODY
SOMEONE WOULD WANT TO BUILD
WHO WAS A PAST MVP AND IT
THEIR OFFENSE AROUND SOMEBODY
REALLY WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
WHO WAS A PAST MVP AND IT
THAT CAM NEWTON WAS STILL
REALLY WASN'T THAT LONG AGO
PLAYING AT A HIGH LEVEL, BUT
THAT CAM NEWTON WAS STILL
I THINK OVER THE LAST COUPLE
PLAYING AT A HIGH LEVEL, BUT
YEARS WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
I THINK OVER THE LAST COUPLE
SPECIAL THAT INJURY TO HIS
YEARS WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
SHOULDER. IT'S JUST I JUST
SPECIAL THAT INJURY TO HIS
I HATE TO SAY THE CAM NEWTON
SHOULDER. IT'S JUST I JUST
HAD SOMETHING TO PROVE
I HATE TO SAY THE CAM NEWTON
BECAUSE HE WASN'T IN VP RIGHT
HAD SOMETHING TO PROVE
LIKE THEY
BECAUSE HE WASN'T IN VP RIGHT
TO THE SUPER BOWL ARE 15 AND
LIKE THEY
ONE ISN'T A SILLY APPLE DOES
TO THE SUPER BOWL ARE 15 AND
BECAUSE HE STILL HAS TO PROVE
ONE ISN'T A SILLY APPLE DOES
THAT HE CAN STAY HEALTHY AND
BECAUSE HE STILL HAS TO PROVE
BE AN EFFECTIVE PASSER FOR A
THAT HE CAN STAY HEALTHY AND
17 GAME SEASON, SO I DON'T
BE AN EFFECTIVE PASSER FOR A
LIKE USING THAT TERM BUT IT'S
17 GAME SEASON, SO I DON'T
THE ONLY TERM THAT'S COMING
LIKE USING THAT TERM BUT IT'S
WELL TO THE EXTENT WE TALK IM
THE ONLY TERM THAT'S COMING
ABOUT GUYS FINDING MOTIVATION
WELL TO THE EXTENT WE TALK IM
AND BEING DOUBTED. THERE
ABOUT GUYS FINDING MOTIVATION
AREN'T MANY QUARTERBACKS
AND BEING DOUBTED. THERE
BEING DOUBTED MORE CURRENTLY
AREN'T MANY QUARTERBACKS
THAN CAM NEWTON IN THE NFL.
BEING DOUBTED MORE CURRENTLY
SO IF THAT'S WHERE HE'S
THAN CAM NEWTON IN THE NFL.
LOOKING FOR MOTIVATION IF
SO IF THAT'S WHERE HE'S
THAT'S HOW HE'S WIRED. HE
LOOKING FOR MOTIVATION IF
DOESN'T HAVE TO MAKE IT UP.
THAT'S HOW HE'S WIRED. HE
UP. HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
DOESN'T HAVE TO MAKE IT UP.
PRETEND THAT. SOMEBODY SAID
UP. HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
SOMETHING BAD ABOUT HIM THE
PRETEND THAT. SOMEBODY SAID
NIGHT BEFORE HE GOES OUT AND
SOMETHING BAD ABOUT HIM THE
HAS A BIG GAME. YEAH. I MEAN,
NIGHT BEFORE HE GOES OUT AND
IT'S LOOK EVERYONE IS
HAS A BIG GAME. YEAH. I MEAN,
DOUBTING NOT EVERYONE BUT A
IT'S LOOK EVERYONE IS
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE JUST LIKE
DOUBTING NOT EVERYONE BUT A
IS THIS REALLY THE GUY IN
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE JUST LIKE
2015? NO, HOW CLOSE IS HE TO
IS THIS REALLY THE GUY IN
BEING THAT GUY AND HOW CLOSE
2015? NO, HOW CLOSE IS HE TO
CAN YOU EVER COME TO BUYEI ANGG